la tercera fue la vencida y joe biden
llegó a la presidencia de eeuu 3
neisinger sporting
a los ciudadanos de esta nación han
hablado nos han entregado una clara
victoria una contundente victoria
prometo no ser un presidente que dé vida
sino que una que no vea estados rojos o
azules solo estados unidos united states
con 77 años joe biden reúne casi 5
décadas de carrera política
nacido en scranton pensilvania pasó la
mayor parte de su vida en el estado de
delaware tras graduarse de la escuela de
derecho del estado dirigió una exitosa
campaña al senado de eeuu en 1972
convirtiéndose en uno de los senadores
más jóvenes en el cargo
[Música]
pero justo después de ganar las
elecciones su esposa y su hija de un año
murieron en un accidente de tránsito
consideró renunciar a su asiento pero
finalmente se mantuvo y se volvió a
casar en 1977 después de perder las
primarias demócratas de 2008 ante barack
obama se convirtió en su compañero de
fórmula
ambos terminaron forjando un estrecho
vínculo
muchos pensaron que biden se postularía
para la presidencia en 2016 pero una
nueva tragedia lo golpeó cuando su hijo
murió de cáncer cerebral
[Aplausos]
en 2020 bardem ganó la candidatura
demócrata a la presidencia entre una
lista de 27 aspirantes es reconocido por
su compromiso de capacidad de superación
pero el ala más izquierdista de su
partido critica su postura moderada en
la campaña baiden se destacó por
expresar empatía hacia los votantes y su
voluntad de luchar contra la pandemia
del hobbit 19 bailén ha prometido calmar
los ánimos y ha endurecido el tono
después de que manifestantes de trump
atacar en el capitolio impulsados por
acusaciones sin fundamento de un
supuesto fraude electoral
byd en ahora acusa a trump de atentar
contra los cimientos de la democracia
estadounidense